so why is it that we hate to win When
God says um he's with you wherever you
are but when it comes to God descending
we don't make it okay so there's both of
them
no because
there's Pizza we will choose explain the
verse based upon the context there's no
problem with that and there is a we
should remove the the the diverse away
from its meaning so what do we say about
Allah is with us with his knowledge
because the verse itself is finished
with the end
so
it says descending
um to forgive his servants so if someone
says this means he's descending with his
mercy
no no because the reason I share it on
other groups they they try to negate
Allah he says the lowest Heaven the wave
of his majesty because of their
so-called sounds the intellect it's not
because of the text or because other
proofs but because you understand so
that's why we reject the explanation of
the Ayah which they remove it away
because now okay let's say Allah's Mercy
descends Allah's Mercy come from who
above it
Allah's Mercy descends so that Mercy is
coming from who yeah I wouldn't say Alex
now without his Mercy in the same way
you say God is everywhere with his
knowledge but he's above the throne
without saying God is separate from the
attribute anyway no but when you say
Allah that's my friend my point is when
they say because
Allah
so I'll say when they say the mercy of
Allah descends so the question that asks
them from who they said from Allah you
establish Allah above the creation they
said no no we don't put in a place
is
that no the Hadith is clear Allah
descends to say it doesn't mean that
then you have to bring us another Hadi
or reverse expenditure ways but don't
say when the prophet said Allah descends
to the lowest Heaven the word of his
majesty and he said Allah speaks
mm-hmm anyone that wants to seek
forgiveness or forgive them Allah to
forgive the people understand so the
other verse is like I mentioned because
the verse is the context clearly speaks
of Allah's knowledge Allah's knowledge
everywhere the attributes living Allah
knows everything yeah yeah
we will choose based upon a context
the president
there's only known to Allah like certain
verses uh they're unclear so where's the
place no the the the verse here there's
two color ads
you stop here
and there is except
Muslims know what is the meaning of it
but the reality is because there's also
there's not I mean we I mean the outcome
of something the reality of something
okay right
for the house not for the meaning
okay
we make some food of the cave oh yeah
that's right
you know why because Allah told us to
call upon him with his names okay so if
we don't know the meaning of the names
what's the point to use them
somebody goes okay you understand
but listen check check
that's good check uh about a yard a
website called.com
yeah yeah above the front let's come
here yeah